[Music]
one day
in 1944 my family
and i were arrested packed into cattle
trains
with no food or water we were taken to
poland
and left on the selection platform in
auschwitz
energy garden spotted me
and my identical twin sister miriam
clinging to my mother he tore
us from my mother's arms
and led us away i remember looking back
at my mother i did not know at that time
but i would never see her again
[Music]
on the filthy floor where the scattered
corpses of
three little girls their bodies were
naked
and their eyes were wide open it was a
horrifying look i have never seen
anybody dead before so that hit me very
very hard and i
made a silent pleasure that i will do
whatever is within my power to make sure
that miriam and i will not end up
on that latrine floor and that we
somehow will
survive and walk out of this camp alive
we were naked for hours
and every part of our bodies was
measured
it was horrible and humiliating
too bad she's so young she has
only two weeks to live i knew
he was right but i refused to die
if i died miriam would have been given a
lethal
injection so he could cut open
both of our bodies and compare
the autopsies for the following two
weeks
i was between life and death
and all i remember crawling on the back
floor
because i no longer could walk and as i
was crawling
i would fade in and out of consciousness
and i kept telling myself i must survive
i must survive
nine months later we returned home
only to find that nobody else
from our family survived to find
only three crumbled pictures
and that was all that was left of my
family
in 1987 i donated one of my kidneys to
safer
but she died in 1993
and i was devastated she was
the only one from the family who was
alive
i was angry
[Music]
i was heading to germany to meet the
nazi doctor
i was unbelievably nervous
and scared dr munch at the time was
82 years old he greeted me with
kindness respect and consideration
i was blown away a nazi treating me with
respect
dr hans much was a bacteriologist at
auschwitz
but he also had a secondary job
that he was stationed outside
the gas chambers and when
people were dead he would sign one
death certificate no names
just the number of people who were
murdered
and he said to me this is my problem
this is a nightmare that i live with i
asked him if he was willing to go with
me
to auschwitz and make the same statement
that he made to me
and he said he would love to
i knew that was a crazy idea to thank a
nazi a survivor of auschwitz
to thank a nazi people would think that
i have lost
my mind i tried to figure out how to
thank him
and after 10 months a simple idea popped
into my head
how about a letter of forgiveness from
me
the survivor of auschwitz i knew that
that was a meaningful gift for him
but what i discovered for myself was
life-changing
that i had the power to forgive
no one could give me that power no one
could take it away
to challenge myself i decided i could
even forgive mengele the person who had
put me through hell
it wasn't easy but i felt an enormous
weight
had been lifted from me i finally
felt free who decided
that i as a victim must be for the rest
of my
life sad angry
feel hopeless and helpless i refuse it
you can never change what happened in
the past
all you can do is change how you react
to it
my sister and i were made into human
guinea pigs
our whole family was murdered but
i have the power to forgive and so
do you
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bell to receive
notifications for new videos
see you again soon